hello guys it's me silver at and I'm
going to do what I've been longing to do
for a long time right now and let's make
a let's play operatic asking three and
um basically I've uploaded let's play on
my tutorial channel but now I've decided
that a tutorial channels [ __ ] wait
you can just put everything on one
channel I don't even know why I make
that channel in the first place but um
basically I'm going to build a pike
without any planning beforehand and I'm
just going to see how it turns out so um
I want to start off with an entrance
without anything else you know what a
classical theme would kind of be awesome
because I've never really tried one um
but how to do a classical entrance it's
actually kind of hard let's see well I
want to keep their usual entrance layout
which is just a few towers and some
spaces in the middle we have ticket
booths and all that kind of [ __ ] so
small pitched roofs not [ __ ] ones um
some of these I think I like to keep it
white just like the classical theme you
know eighty three and just that make
them about five high I guess now that's
way too mo mm how about 6 6 s decent I
guess that that's ok I don't know how it
turns out but um let's just start off
with the pillars anyway now I would have
some big bottoms over here [ __ ] that was
a long sentence forget about that
I've never really seen anybody do this
because I've seen plenty of classical
buildings and plenty of entrances but
not really two of them combined together
with elements from both of them mmm
those where are you at
there you go okay this is going to take
a while let's skip that hmm this is
actually not bad well I really have to
do is add some of these pediments
nothing all the kind of decent now wow I
just messed up um realistically speaking
I should add a freeze to all of these
for one to be close to the real
architecture from like Roman times but
um screw all of that I mean these little
roofs are too small anyway I don't want
to have them these ducts monstrosity is
or something mm-hmm now I do want a
little base wall so get over here and um
probably some bigger walls on the sides
here yeah not bad now I could add it I
could add like two domes on the sides
I think that'll look cool oops I think
this is actually yeah somewhat simple
but still okay looking a general layout
for the first entrance building still
gonna have to add some ticket booths and
all that kind of [ __ ] what do you
even at those hang on you can't have to
look that up
all right so apparently I'm going to
have to put ticket booths inside of
these things but hey [ __ ] off I have no
idea how to built those so I'm going to
have to lift it up and probably download
one or two sets for that so that's going
to be annoying um but anyway I want to
continue with these little domes inside
here and then just download some sad to
see if I have some sets which I can use
for ticket booths and then come back
through this
I don't want any Brown brothers probably
out nope now I'm messing this up I need
to piss
this is not bad now I just need to add
some ballast trades on the top beautiful
beautiful absolutely stunning so far so
good now I just need some posts because
these ballast rates are floating I'm a
very slow build I think I'm pretty sure
some people are much faster at this than
I am
and I tend to mess up every few seconds
but I do like the light I do like the
like I do like the look of this so far
now I don't think this said it has any
round things in it or any domes which is
such a pity but it's it's not a problem
because I've got a church SATs that's
right I'm mixing medieval I'm mixing
medieval architecture with classical
architecture here this is the real deal
this is what what humanity's been
waiting for this is this is pure
innovation um all right domes is this a
good height yeah that's perfect
all right so far so good
now all I really need to do now is just
add some walls to these things basically
but exactly how it's taken Lance I think
I'll just start with adding a border in
the middle because these these things
aren't going to have two floors yeah
that's okay and then just add some
windows around that lots and lots of
windows I mean if you call Matt if you
can't find anything to just decorate
your building with just use Windows
windows everywhere
it'll make building beautiful not bad
but it's kind of repetitive I'm just
going to add some different windows in
the top floor and yes this
fantastic now all it really needs is
something something over here something
like a balcony I guess let's see I'm
pretty sure Main Street yup let's see oh
that's perfect
not not fits perfectly I'll go with that
thank you very much symmetry
oh that's it's kind of beautiful but now
I really need something to and in the
middle of these hmm ha turns up this
side is exactly what I needed that is
some some seal charge windows whatever
there they are
it's little windows where people can buy
tickets and all that so it's exactly
what I need and turns out that these
stripes kind of fit the whole classical
theme as well I mean their wives and
Brides and um not that bad
so I'm going with this this is kind of
boring though hmm no I'm not doing that
I will turn styles oh thank you that's
at that as well
whoops good place no I've got normal
ones I've got nor modern ones it's kind
of a bit cool then our cages it's come
on it's not a prison and then again
these ones are kind of too low to be you
know believable yeah I'll just add some
cages in here or more in there I just
really matter
mmm but I want to get rid of that blue
texture that's a tread just so it's the
same color as the roof
yeah I guess it's acceptable now there
should be some fences as well here ha
iron gates and he's always look cool
yeah not bad now I just have to add some
walls in between and is there anything
else we can use doesn't really seem like
there's anything too interesting mmm
could I use these over here I wonder now
the kind of weird and more generic I
don't want generic at the moment nice
some of these could be handy but I'm not
not adding those mmm
I wanna have some classical walls in
between there so back to antique world
and some brick walls hmm yeah mmm let's
see I just need you one H brick wall
over there
how's this place what's what ah damn it
it's hard to see anything in there okay
now I just have to come up with
something for the top because as now
it's it's too empty let's see okay I've
got crazy with this building but um mmm
it's kind of a mess right now but it's
not that bad
but the only problem I have with this is
that it's currently just [ __ ] on top of
each other and just one big pile of
stuff basically so um yeah I want to win
oh look like I can remove these on the
sides and then just add something else
there well this is kind of empty again
oh wait that looks a lot better if I
could just add some ballast right over
there that might look okay oh yeah this
is starting to look good let's see a
small vase or whatever it is and uh
please just a little more detail to the
building and then we can start building
on the roof just want to have a simple
roof but then adds a very small dome or
something like that on the roof because
otherwise it's too flat and boring
I don't like flat and boring I love the
combination of red and white in this
building yeah I definitely need
something in the middle over there okay
so I've got a little concrete circle in
the middle here and now I just need to
add some pillars and stuff like that now
this does look a lot better so I'm glad
I did that at least it's still a little
bit higher when I compare it to the
domes insides so I'm not entirely sure
about the domes on the sides but they're
a little bit too big again I don't know
now I get the site that I wanted to get
rid of the domes inside they really made
the building in the middle look a lot
smaller and now it looks more like an
entrance building and a lot less like I
went to impress you with these great
domes and [ __ ] and bla bla bla bla
bla basically I just had an idea in the
spur of the moment I just thought of
making a Plaza in here and have some
galleries with pillows run all the way
around them and have some cool buildings
and stuff and as fountain in the middle
and oh my gosh and romantic and all that
kind of stuff so I'm going for that so
um now just for the moment I haven't
found a clock yet so in the middle of
the bell tower so I'm going to put
whatever it found in or something like
that in the middle but if anybody knows
is sat with a good-looking Bell that
would fit inside this tower
um suggestions are always welcome and I
would really appreciate it if I got
something cool for in this tower because
a fountain scanner man
you know it's kind of weird actually but
yeah on to the pillars on the galleries
and the plaza mmm I want to start off
with a basic layout of course so here
let's see I'm going to do time lapse of
starts hold on
okay so what I've got now is just the
entrance building with a little war
around it and next time I'm going to add
a Plaza art in here and have a ferris
wheel or a carousel or something like
that in the middle and I want to start
working on my first ghost as well soon
and maybe I'll even build a Main Street
or is something like that anyways we'll
see you next time
so till then
you